Der Potsdamer Platz heute
und in den 20er Jahren:
Damals war es der
verkehrsreichste Platz Europas
– dann ein Brachland, menschenleer,
mitten in der Stadt.
Denn mit dem Bau der Mauer 1961
wird der Potsdamer Platz
Teil des streng bewachten Todesstreifens.
Die ersten Segmente werden zwei Tage
nach dem Mauerfall 1989 abgetragen.
Die Menschen strömen durch
die offene Grenze.
1994 beginnt der Wiederaufbau –
der Potsdamer Platz wird
zur größten Baustelle Europas.
Nach nur sechs Jahren ist das
Projekt weitgehend fertig.
Vor allem Hochhäuser prägen
die neue Silhouette,
gebaut von den Star-Architekten Helmut
Jahn, Hans Kollhoff und Renzo Piano.
Die riesige Lücke im Herzen der
Hauptstadt ist geschlossen.
Der Potsdamer Platz wird zum Symbol
für das neue, wiedervereinte Berlin.
Pflastersteine markieren den Verlauf
der abgerissenen Mauer.
Wenige Mauerteile sind wieder aufgestellt.
Dazu gib es Schautafeln.
Man müsste mehr davon sehen, gerade weil
das so ein historischer Ort ist.
Die Mauerteile finde ich gut,
aber man hätte hier die geschichtliche
Bedeutung mehr wertschätzen sollen.
Hier gibt es sehr interessante
Informationen;
die sind schon sehr hilfreich für Besucher
wie mich, die noch nie in Berlin waren.
Glas, Stahl und Beton:
Der Potsdamer Platz ist wieder ein
pulsierendes Zentrum in Berlin.